i'd like to welcome everyone to our
google cloud
next on error session my name is ryan
lippert product manager at google cloud
and i'm going to be joined by daniel
lewis from geotab
daniel's a senior data scientist and
research specialist for geotab
a company which works in the telematics
space that is instrumenting vehicles to
learn how to optimize fleet maintenance
routes costs and even city
infrastructure now to give you an idea
of how hard that can be
daniel's previous life was implementing
machine learning on brain images
so not exactly a brain surgeon but more
of the person telling the brain surgeon
what needs to happen
so kidding around aside the theme of
what we'll be rolling through is how
daniel and geotab
were able to use google cloud's analytic
tools to make the their analysis
of their business run easier or in their
words
don't sweat the big stuff make it
google's problem so let's take a look at
the agenda for this session
we'll start by kicking things off with a
brief overview of bigquery
then i'll pass things off to daniel for
the exciting piece of the conversation
and at the end we'll bring things back
around and ask daniel a few follow-up
questions about his work
so let's go ahead and get started with
bigquery the real-time
cloud-scale data warehouse now when it
comes to analytics
we've seen advancements across different
types of databases data lakes
data engineering tools business
intelligence and more but the reality is
that the data warehouse still forms the
foundation for analytics programs across
most businesses
this is important to recognize because
it highlights the need to bring users
new capabilities not just through new
tools but through new features in their
existing tools
particularly the data warehouse now when
we think of bigquery it's helpful to
compare and contrast it with the
traditional edw
environments and those were
traditionally complicated to get data
into
restricted to only a few users optimized
for old-fashioned business intelligence
optimized for batch data they were in
need of constant patching
and you needed quite a few
administrators for the operational tasks
now when you hear from daniel shortly
you immediately know that this kind of
tech wasn't going to work for geotab
now when we look at bigquery it comes at
this space from a very different
perspective
we automate delivery into the data
warehouse we make insights accessible
through the ability to scale out that
data warehouse
we enable ml and ai from within the data
warehouse
and bigquery can do this all in real
time while protecting your data
and simplifying operations so when you
bring this all together it has a
dramatic impact on your business
and that dramatic impact is just how
much time you're able to spend
generating analysis and insights
when daniel talks about not sweating the
big stuff it's a lot of what you see in
this grade
area from traditional data warehouses
difficult people-intensive processes
that are about technology and not about
insights now from google cloud's
perspective
we think the hard part is the applied
analysis and the insights our customers
like geotab
are generating we're happy to handle the
back-end technology part
and let customers focus on analyzing the
specific domains that they know
like nobody else now before i pass
things off to daniel
i'd like to quickly highlight a unique
feature of bigquery that
when combined with bigquery ml helps
make some of geotabs analysis possible
and that's bigquery gis now many people
know
google has long been an innovator and a
leader in geodata with more than a
billion people using google maps each
month
with bigquery gis google cloud makes it
possible to do core gis
functions directly in bigquery with
familiar sql statements
so with that i finished off serving up
the appetizer for this session
and we can move on to the main course
that everyone's been waiting for i'm
going to pass things off to daniel
who's going to take you through how he
and geotab have put google's technology
to work
in building out an impressive business
thanks ryan so at geotab we make
internet of things devices
these little hardware devices that plug
into the obd2 port of vehicles
to enable smart telematics solutions i'm
talking about telematics solutions
generally that's for fleets and these
little devices are used to track those
vehicles
and help companies make better decisions
for managing their individual vehicles
and ultimately operational efficiencies
across their entire fleet so we've got a
pretty small data science team at geotab
though it's grown significantly the last
couple years
but we're able to do so much for our
customers because we can rely on google
to handle all the big back-end stuff
and allow us to really focus on spending
time to solve our customers business
problems and our own internal business
problems
so today we're going to talk about going
from all of those individual telematics
devices
and kind of the customer levels how you
can bubble that up using google's
awesome
scalable back-end tools to produce
globally scalable analytics leveraging
the whole google cloud ecosystem of
tools
so as of today we've got devices
installed in more than two million
vehicles around the world and as i'm
talking you can look at this really
beautiful map in the background which
shows um just a single day of
vehicle coverage in north america from
our connected devices
so these devices are constantly
streaming data back about the vehicle's
position its speed its acceleration
the rpms engine status information
coolant temperature
oil temperature fault codes there's a
onboard accelerometer we're going to be
adding a gyroscope and just tons of
information constantly streaming back
now server side this results in over 40
billion data points per day which is
just terabytes of information on our end
just constantly streaming
so managing that streaming process alone
that's already a huge scalability
challenge
it's one that we solved with google's
tools among many other problems that
we've encountered but
due to time limitations today we're just
going to focus on what we do
after we get all of that data which is
where my job really comes in and the
part that i get really excited about and
find really interesting
so what do we actually do with all of
this data these you know 40 billion data
points that we're getting every single
day so 40 billion data points is really
great it's awesome i love working with
that amount of data but
just the data sitting there is not
actionable in any way for anybody
no human can go in and just like you
look through that information and try to
parse it and
get anything actionable out of it just
by looking at it so what we want to
provide to our customers
are things like solutions something that
actually solves the business problem
using that data
we do a lot of things focused around a
few different key areas some of them
that are really interesting for our
fleet customers our predictive
maintenance solutions
preventing breakdowns before they happen
predicting battery failures that kind of
thing these roadside breakdowns are very
expensive
we want to use all this data that's
coming off the engine to prevent that
from happening
we do things like artificial
intelligence driven smarter fleet
management
and today's focus is going to be more on
kind of the broader network scale things
so smart city analytics
and solutions to make kind of less
congested and just generally more
efficient cities around the world
which is a win-win for everybody
involved
so why do we care about congestion it's
a really big problem
if you're looking at just north america
congestion caused urban americans so not
even all of america just urban regions
to travel an extra 8.8 billion
hours this was in 2019 for a congestion
cost of 166 billion dollars so
it's a bit of a problem these are just
numbers for america it's an even bigger
problem globally so we definitely want
to do something to solve this
or make it a little bit better if we can
now there's
20 000 cities in america so
most of those are really small but it's
still a lot of cities and there are
multitudes more around the world so it
seems maybe a little bit intractable to
start thinking about how we can optimize
infrastructure across
twenty thousand thirty thousand a
hundred thousand cities but little small
improvements really do matter they can
scale you can make these little bit
biggy changes and you know across
hundreds of thousands of individuals you
can
wind up with really big cumulative
impacts so just an example in san
francisco
i looked up the numbers there and we've
got you know a few hundred thousand
people
entering in cars in san francisco every
single day you know on their way to work
and if they have to stop at only
five individual intersections in the
city and we're somehow able to
shave three seconds off their average
stop time we're gonna save 375 hours of
idling every single day giving each
commuter an hour of their life back
this is great for the commuter it's
great for the city you know getting more
people through less congestion
less impacts on the environment it's a
win-win for everybody involved
in order to improve anything though we
need to know what the current reality is
we need to know what the current state
is so that we can push forward in
a direction that we want to improve and
we have to start with data we have to
start with a lot of it
as you saw from our previous slide so
here's an example of the type of thing
that we might want to produce for a city
so on the left there you can see a heat
map of downtown san francisco
and the heat map is just colored by the
average wait time in seconds for a given
hour of the day
in the city now imagine that you could
just zoom into any city in the world and
access this kind of detailed information
for every single intersection in that
city
without any kind of infrastructure
changes no camera installation
no strips to lay down no trenches to dig
and put strips in no one's standing at
the corner with a clipboard and
stopwatch which
in talking to cities amazingly this
still happens imagine you could just get
all this information instantly from all
of the cars that are already driving
around you don't have to do anything
this is really what we're trying to
achieve and this is what you can do when
you leverage google cloud because of the
volumes of information that we're able
to handle with that
back end so to achieve this goal in this
particular talk here we're going to
restrict the scope a little bit to
something a little bit more manageable
and that's going to be focusing on
signal controlled intersections so these
are the things that the city can tweak
immediately to get some short-term
feedback on impacts
and iteratively move towards a better
solution
so this is the kind of thing that we're
thinking about when we're talking about
traffic light optimizations going in and
removing a stop sign or adding a stop
sign or adding or removing lanes adding
dedicated right turn lanes
you know coming up with you know diamond
interchanges these kind of things total
infrastructure changes
are things that you definitely have to
consider and they have large impacts on
traffic congestion
but they're not something that can be
easily or cheaply manipulated or changed
with traffic signals you can make
improvements with just the lights though
if we're looking at something simple
like a north south or east-west
direction intersection like we've got
here
how much green do you allocate to each
direction that's an optimization problem
if you've got you know 70 second 140
second whatever it is light cycle time
there's only a certain amount of green
that can be allocated in either
direction if you give it more in one
direction it has to be taken from the
other direction
and that has impacts upstream and
downstream so how do you actually know
what's better
and is the problem at this intersection
or is it upstream or downstream of this
intersection
you know on a particular day is it
because of the normal cyclical traffic
flows or is it because of an accident
etc
we need a lot of data to be able to
determine what the optimal light timing
actually
is for any given intersection and what
the impacts would be on the network if
we were to change it
so that's the type of question that
we're trying to answer with our data
however streaming a lot of data is very
very expensive so it's getting cheaper
all the time and when you're talking
about millions of vehicles constantly
streaming data
those little bits of cost add up pretty
quickly
we can't do continuous data sampling
we've got real devices real hardware
limitations
with local storage limitations as well
real data transfer costs we need to
figure out what the ideal sample rate is
so what's the ideal sample rate so you
don't miss for example going around
corners as you go around a corner
there's a lot of different things
happening we don't want to miss the
corner etc so you need a higher sample
frequency than
if you're just going in a straight line
down a freeway for example if we were to
constantly drop points you know every
tenth of a second or something we're
bringing back a lot of redundant
information because we know you're just
going in a straight line down the
highway
if you have a uniform sample rate you
can't really solve both of those
problems simultaneously if you crank up
the sample rate
such that you're cussing and catching
those corners you're going to be sending
back way more information that you need
in areas that you don't actually need it
we solve this at geotab with something
called curve logic it's kind of a symbol
of a very elegant idea that we use to
minimize the data transfer costs we've
got a couple patents on it listed there
and the basic idea is really simple you
can watch the cool animation there on
the right while i describe it but
essentially
you just have a high frequency sampling
on the actual hardware device
and then that's stored in a local
storage buffer before you send that back
you go through that buffer and you
choose points from the sequence of high
frequency sample points
such that linearly interpolating between
them which is what you kind of see with
these red dots there
no intervening dropped point would be
more than some chosen error threshold
away from the line and that's just a
parameter that you can tweak depending
on your use case
and then from the device to the server
only sending back those individual
points
where we were in linearly interpolating
between so only those red points get
sent back to the server
so we use this technique to really
efficiently send the minimal amount of
data back to our servers and enables
accurate trip reconstruction
so when you're going in a straight line
down the highway we may only need to
drop down one or two points
from your initial point in order to tell
that you're still on that highway and
when you go on the off ramp we're gonna
drop a whole bunch of points and send
those back to the save
server to make sure that we didn't miss
your turn off that off ramp
now when we do this we come back and we
start looking at the data in bigquery
and on our visualizer tools and that
kind of thing you know the first obvious
thing that's going to happen is now
we've got gaps
so on the server side all these gaps we
know in reality you would have had to
have driven through that little green
circle that intersection there in order
to get from one side of fulton street to
the other side of fulton street so how
are we going to fill in all of these
gaps server side
we know that because we did the curve
logic that linearly interpolating
between those two points we would have
never been more than the air threshold
that we chose
away from those so we've got our two
million vehicles generating billions of
points we know that in order to fill
them in we can just
linearly interpolate between them but
with two million vehicles billions of
points how are we going to actually do
that in a scalable way
we don't want to just linearly
interpolate necessarily at a huge
resolution in areas we don't need it
again but we want to make sure we don't
miss the the intersections
um in our particular use case because we
are focused on high quality
data reproduction for these
intersections we're going to drop them
at a scale
that allows us to ensure that we've got
coverage in every single geohash of
interest which i'll get to
later to do efficient spatial joins in
our case that's a little bit under 9
meters
so we've got 2 million vehicles 40
billion points a day we have to fill in
all of these gaps at a resolution of 9
meters
as you can imagine that's a really
difficult process involving connecting
tons of different systems trying to
scale out and paralyze the interpolation
et cetera
nope not at all just kidding about that
with google you don't need to sweat that
big stuff
end to end we never leave the google
ecosystem for this project we just make
the big stuff google's problem entirely
let them handle the hard back end work
so as you can see on the slide there
with the details on the right we run a
daily interpolation for all of our
vehicles and this actually runs in less
than 20 minutes
all you have to do is you know work in a
little bit of the simple math we're
doing linearly
interpolated point dropping between our
gps points
and google worries about scaling all
that out on the back end in a
parallelizable way we never have to
leave bigquery it's really really really
simple
so we've been able to minimize our data
transfer costs and accurately
reconstruct the trips on the server side
now the reason that we're able to do all
of this super efficiently is because of
the tools that google has been
continually innovating and one of the
things that i mentioned at the beginning
was bqgis this was really a game changer
for us and enabling us to do all the
scaling so july 2018
if i remember correctly is when bigquery
released nato geospatial support
this allowed us to move away from
relying on javascript udfs so those were
really powerful
at the time when we were using them but
they don't scale out as well on the back
end as kind of native bigquery functions
so when we started switching all of that
over to bqgis functions
we were able to really believe in the
scope that we were looking at for this
type of things that before we were
running it on a region to region basis
and now we run this
every single day for the entire world
we're constantly leveraging the qgis
functions and weaving them into
everything that we do
so we've got all of our data back from
the vehicles we've reconstructed these
trips and interpolated the points we've
got all the locations at a very high
spatial resolution so what do we
actually want to do next we have this
data but what we're trying to do is find
these
intersections so that we can track
vehicles through them now this is the
this is the tricky
part so for a proof of concept and for
the purposes of the
presentation we used openstreetmap
traffic signals as our point of
reference to look for intersections
so an intersection is not something
that's actually generally well defined
in a geometric sense in many mapping
solutions
and particularly in osm there's a lot of
possible configurations for
traffic lights and ways to come into an
intersection you can see a sample of
them here
sometimes you've got you know two ways
and three lights sometimes you've got
four ways and one light eight ways and
four lights there's a lot of different
configurations
and there's no real concept of like the
intersection itself or if you imagine
kind of like the polygon that would wrap
around the rows that lead into that
intersection
and it's not so easy then to map these
kind of individual ways and connected
nodes and lights
to something that has a geographic
representation of what the intersection
actually is in terms of what a human
would understand in terms of behavior of
cars through it
so how do we go from some number of
traffic lights and some number of ways
to kind of a single point
and its associated geometry to represent
that intersection and the way that we
solve that is just start with a really
simple algorithm db scan
so we're going to leverage the dv scan
algorithm which is really simple it's
really powerful algorithm it's been used
for decades
and it's really great at finding local
clusters at points however even for this
really simple use case
it really quickly becomes a scalability
problem so if we're looking at the whole
world
osm has about 1.2 million traffic light
nodes this leads us to 742 billion
pairwise combinations of distances
so if you had data storage and a 64-bit
numpy array that's more than five and a
half terabytes of ram already needed
just to store the distance matrix before
you started doing any calculations
so on top of that um db scan is not a
really easy algorithm to parallelize so
you know i'm starting to sweat a bit
this doesn't really seem tractable how
we're gonna do this there must be some
way that we can make this google
google's problem and there definitely is
so we can solve this actually pretty
easily with data flow and data flow is
great at handling this kind of stuff in
the
in the back end so let's utilize some of
the information that we have about the
connectivity
of these lights we're not going in blind
here so we know that some of them are in
certain ways
those waves are connected to other ways
and those waves have lights on them some
of them don't etc so we know something
about the relationship between the nodes
and the waves and how they're
connected in the street network so what
we're going to do is we're going to
utilize those connectivity relationships
to reduce the search space around each
light where it's only calculating
distances to lights that are within some
number of connectivity hops to the light
itself
plus some other connectivity parameters
that we introduce such as the type of
road
road road and street names that type of
thing so these are all hyper parameters
that we can tune in our approach
but assume that we've done that and this
leads us to a markedly reduced number of
pre-clusters
and with those pre-clusters we can then
run a parallelized db scan so when we do
this approach we get about 1.6 million
pre-clusters to perform db scan on
each of those are independent of each
other though so this means that we can
now parallelize it
on average they have nine points or less
which is a much more attractive problem
for db scan it's a much smaller pairwise
distance matrix
so we can basically just throw this at
dataflow now and let it handle all the
hard work of parallelizing this
across all these 1.6 million clusters on
the back end let it scale up the
machines let it worry about how to
distribute the work
how to collect it after and how to
stream it back into bigquery all i had
to do was figure out the approach
so we're able to really easily do this
and this runs pretty fast so now we've
identified 700 000 intersections
in the entire world in less than 10
minutes using just bigquery and data
flow
so this is excellent we still haven't
left the core google cloud product suite
so now we can go onto the next step
which
is mapping the roads so once we have the
intersections we have to accurately map
the rows in order to accurately track
where the vehicles are actually coming
from
and going to so that we can get accurate
metrics at a per interception level
and ultimately chain them together to
get corner analytics and kind of like
broader network effects as well
so in order to efficiently generate
these trips we want to be able to do
a very simple geospatial join so if we
were to do something like a simple knife
cross joining between all of our gps
points and all the roads in the world
and maybe use something like a bqgis
function like std within
we'd have an absolutely astronomical
number of rows so this is not possible
even for google yet it's far more than
bigquery can handle
so there has to be a better smarter way
that we can figure out what road you're
on
really quickly in a scalable way for
these millions and millions of vehicles
and these billions of points
and there is there's a lot of smarter
ways that we can do this and at geotab
we tend to use geohash for geocoding
latitude and longitude so geohash is
just a z-order space filling curve
you can think of it if you haven't used
it before something just like nested
rectangles to cover the whole globe
and any two latitude and longitude pair
inside one of these little rectangular
boxes
gets assigned a string which is unique
to that box and there's a lot of other
mapping systems such as s2 cells h3
cells et cetera but at geo time we tend
to use geohash
and it has native support in bqgis which
is great we don't have to jump out to
javascript udfs
so this allows us to forget about the
impossibility of accurately joining
floats and the impossibility of doing
these cross joins
enables to enables us to do a very fast
straight string join
based on geohash so that's great but
that then leads us into another problem
so if we're going to be doing the
straightjoin on geohash
we have to then know which geohashes are
actually part of the road network
and which parts of the road network are
associated with which intersection
so there are some machine learning
approaches that we've used but they're
actually some simpler clever
ways that you can do leveraging the
ability of bigquery to scale really
efficiently before you even have to get
into the machine learning area
so the hard part back to the problem
which is really a trip generation
problem in order to generate trips again
we need to know what the set of possible
traversals is through any given
intersection to segment the vehicle path
into intersection based trips
so before we even think about
associating the geohashes with the ways
we need to know which ways are
associated with the intersection
so as a first step we can just pull all
the directly connected waves at the
intersection so anything that's directly
touching or connected to a traffic light
so you can exceed an example of that on
the bottom right of the slide
for some random intersection that i just
picked however you can already see on
the map you know the adjacent
intersections to the left right north
and south
are further away than those ways that
are extending so we've got these
directly connected ways but they don't
actually map
all the way to the next intersection so
if you were to just you know base
trips on this they're not actually going
to be accurately reflecting the metrics
for those vehicles we're only going to
be counting vehicles that are on those
lines
assuming we've done the geohash
associated with those lines so we miss
all of the intervening information from
when you left the previous intersection
until you get to these like short
distance approaches here so that's
something we're going to have to fix
so what we actually need to do is start
with all those directly connected ways
and then somehow get all the ways
connected to those
and then all the ways connected to those
and those and so on and so forth going
backwards
until we run out of ways that are
connected or we hit the next
intersection
while simultaneously somehow taking care
not to include side streets and
different types of roads and things like
that so you can see with the code on the
bottom right there it's actually pretty
easy to get all the connected ways it's
a really simple join on the nodes
there's nothing really challenging about
that
so this is ultimately what we want to do
you can see there's like a 132 connected
ways here
so we've got our simple query to join
back and get the connected ways
in this particular case we know how many
there are so we're good to go right we
just keep joining until we've got all
these ways that are highlighted here for
this intersection
but of course it's never quite that easy
so we don't know a priority for any
given intersection how many waves are
connected so we don't know how many
times we need to actually join
so what we're going to have to do is
look recursively until we run out of
connections
in order to scale we know we want to do
this recursion and bigquery and just
leverage sql
unfortunately you can't do recursion in
sql so what are we going to do
or can we so i was super excited about
this and
really recent so in november 2019
bigquery released native scripting
support which is really amazing and
powerful allows you to do really quick
prototyping
experimenting and iteration of things
that weren't really possible before
right inside bigquery and right inside
the ui
so you can run scripts with your api
just like a running ml sql query you can
run it in the ui it's got
all the basic building blocks as well
that you would want in a scripting
language like
conditional execution loops we can mix
dml and sql and it gives us some really
powerful capabilities we're going to
leverage all those capabilities to solve
this conductivity problem
so i was really excited when this came
out and i immediately ran over to the
documentation
and unfortunately the documentation for
this is super underwhelming and they
actually are really underselling the
power and capability of this tool
so if you see on the left there that's
like the example for loops in the
documentation no one would ever
use sql to increment some random
variable x and spit it out at the end of
the loop this is just not a use case
that would happen
this is really the extent of the
documentation that they have for loops
so i wanted to do something a little
more fun to learn it
and then also showcase the power of it
so i went and tried to implement a
recursive fibonacci generator using
nothing but sql and bigquery and the
result is here on the left it totally
works
i wouldn't recommend doing recursive
fibonacci in general and definitely
don't do it in sql
but the point is that this is a really
powerful tool and the things that you
would think are not going to be possible
to implement in sql and weren't before
you can now do really easily in bigquery
and you can copy the code
and left you want and run it it totally
works it's going to hit scaling problems
at some point as it kind of explodes
recursively but the point is that
it works and when we implement this in a
smarter way we can solve things like our
connected waste problem without ever
leaving the sql environment and letting
google handle all that big complicated
backend stuff
so here's some actually usable code so
on the left there is the final code that
i wrote to actually do this with a sql
scripting approach
so what we can do is we can build a
while loop that just keeps joining
backwards and keeps joining backwards
and way nodes until we can't find
anymore
so it's a really simple while loop we
can set some break condition if we want
15 30 100
whatever we like in terms of number of
connected hops and
insert the results of each step into a
reference table at the end of a loop
iteration
and at the start of the loop we just
join back on it with the ways and nodes
in the next loop iteration we just keep
doing this and we just keep doing this
until we hit our
break limit or until the table size
stops changing we know that we've run
out of connected ways
so once you bring in the ability to
leverage loops this actually becomes a
really simple problem to solve
we just take our simple join and we
recursively iterate it so we run out of
connectivity
and then you can just lean on bigquery
and it's awesome ability to scale and
this whole thing actually runs in less
than an hour for the entire world
so google handles the parallelization on
the back end really really well
so here's like the the results of that
in a particular neighborhood this is
just oakville where i live
and this has been done for the entire
world so we've got every single
connected way associated with every
single intersection in the world
so this is really fantastic and in
combination with the data flow step that
we did before
and the couple of bigquery steps we're
still under two hours end to end to do
all of this to get all the connected
ways associated with intersections for
the entire planet
so what do we actually do with it so we
have the roads but this doesn't actually
solve the problem yet
we still need all of those associated
geohashes and we're back to our original
cross-joint problem
except instead of geographic points we
now have geohashes so we still can't
just join these geohashes on the roads
um the geohashes that cover the whole
planet and figure out which road they're
on so we've still got 20 billion
geohashes and 18 million ways after the
reduction step
that's still a 386 quintillion row cross
joint
that's still way too much for bigquery
to handle so again we need to come up
with a smarter clever
more clever way to do this now google's
really good at scaling which is the
point i'm trying to drive home in this
presentation so if you can craft the
problem in such a way that the hard part
is
scaling at least within astronomical
limits you pretty much won because
google can just handle all that for you
so let's do that
so let's think a little bit more
carefully about the problem and create
it in such a way
that we're stuck on a scaling problem
and then just throw it at google and let
it
deal with that for us so what we can do
is actually break this problem down into
two primary steps first what we need is
actually a subset of close by geohashes
from there we can restrict the set of
geohashes in some way to those that just
cover the road and then
we are back to our original problem
where we have our interpolated gps
points and because we can easily get
geohashes for those points directly with
bqgs
it's just a straight join no cross join
required anymore and now we've got
something that's going to work really
well and it's going to scale really well
so we can't just geo hash the nodes that
make up the ways those are
unevenly spaced on the road so we're
going to get gaps we could start with
that maybe and look at like parent nodes
neighbor nodes
um apparent neighbor geohashes et cetera
but we're going to have a lot of edge
cases to deal with there
and those arrays kind of don't scale
super well we know the cross joins
aren't going to work so how are we going
to actually do this so
what we need to do is make some sort of
search base ourselves we can do this
using just sql udfs and bpgis again
so all we really need to start with is
some reduced search space which we can
visualize as a bounding box
with some incremental spacing from one
side of the bounding box to another this
gives us basically a matrix of
possibilities
um of lat long points that we've kind of
stepped through we're going to convert
each of those into a geohash using bqgis
and then only retain those geohashes
that are within some distance of the
road
we can let google then handle the big
stuff which is scaling out this approach
to the entire world
so this is the result of our first pass
on a randomly selected road what we've
done is surrounded this particular road
with a bounding box which you can see on
the left there
it's very easy to do just by getting the
extents of the geometry and adding some
buffer space and then we have this kind
of wrapped box around the road
and then we simply use bigquery to
generate an array where we step by an
amount smaller than the geohash
dimensions of interest and i'm kind of
taking into account
the distance from the equator because
they're not perfectly linear the earth
is not flat
and then we geocode these points of that
long into our grid of geohashes and then
voila
we've covered the whole road with
geohashes so from there we can now
finally do our std within function that
we were talking about several slides ago
that's just a singular geometry
comparison for each way and it's
potentially associated geohashes instead
of this massive cross drawing which
isn't possible
so now we've done this std within
function and we've got all of the
geohashes that are covering the road
we get the estimated road width based on
things like the number of lanes the
geographical region
of interest um the prescribed kind of uh
maximum minimum roadways for a given
municipality etc and we've got some
models that do that and now we've got a
wonderfully reduced set of geohashes
that accurately covers the road itself
so once we parallelize this a few times
with modbuy this actually runs in less
than four hours for the entire planet
so here's an example of just all of the
intersection roads in singapore for fun
and so remember that we never left
bigquery for any of this i never looked
at any data from singapore
um you know i picked a few local
examples figured out how to best kind of
cleverly come up with a process that
leverages the ability of bigquery to
scale
and then we're going from basically a
text string representing the geography
of a roadway which is stored in
bigquery without any direct relationship
to the intersection to a set of all of
the geohashes covering all the roads in
the entire world that lead up into a
particular intersection
using nothing but sql and we still spend
for this whole pipeline
only around six hours from end to end to
run so all in a day's work we've gone
from
some simple text strings to
representative geohashes covering the
entire planet
so now we can actually go and start
generating metrics for the cities and
this was the purpose of kind of doing
all this to begin with
so since we have intersections with
labels and all their associated
geohashes now their centers their bounds
etc
all we have to do is geocode our vehicle
path gps points into geohashes and then
join back on this intersections table
that we've created
from there we can easily assign each
portion of a trip to the intersection
that it passes through next
and from there it's a simple matter of
tracking things like speed the number of
stops
the idle time the idle time per stop the
total distance traveled
to the point from which you first stop
which we can use to infer queue lengths
and things like that
to pull out really any metric of
interest and subsequently aggregate up
to the time period of interest
so if you imagine um you're traveling
out of your driveway and you get onto
the road
and at some point on that road you're
gonna hit an intersection where you have
to make a turn decision or straight
through decision
so the point from which you leave that
driveway into the point which you get to
that intersection is going to be
one subset of your total trip that
subset has a bunch of metrics associated
with it and get associated with that
intersection that you then passed
through
from the moment that you leave that
intersection we start counting again
towards the next intersection that you
experience and so on and so forth then
we break up all of your driving
into these little trip segments that are
associated with a given intersection
an example there on the on the right
there is just for the region of toronto
so using that aggregated information we
can now really easily generate all sorts
of insights for any city where we've got
vehicles and as you saw in one of our
first slides there that's pretty much
any city in north america
and we're expanding globally as well so
you can see some cool examples on the
slide here
so on the left we've got the average
trip volume for heavy duty vehicles
you can see that they tend to prefer
certain quarters through the city and
this is the las vegas region
on the top right for las vegas as well
we've got a quarter analysis heat map of
individual trips through a sequence of
intersection
and this essentially shows you the
propensity to have to stop at any given
intersection along the corridor
on the bottom right is just a simple
heat map example showing the percentage
of vehicles that have to stop at any
given intersection
based on the turn direction if you look
closely you can see some interesting
patterns there like uh
rush hour times depending on the
direction at certain times of day around
8 am and around 5 and 6 pm
and at the bottom there you can actually
see two right turns one of which
has a significantly higher propensity to
stop than the other one and if you go
and look on the map it's because that
turn direction has a dedicated right
turn lane
um and the other one doesn't so the one
where you don't have to stop has a
dedicated turn line and
little things like that are really easy
to pick out of these things and really
validate the infrastructure changes that
you've been making
and then with this kind of information
we can roll it up to any time period of
interest so you could do you know for
example a few week period
before a light change change the light
timing and look at a few week period
after and measure if there were any
differences
and doing this throughout the entire
city and looking at the network effects
upstream and downstream you can really
start to optimize
and shave off those few seconds that we
were talking about that gives people
back
you know time and money of their day and
really helps reduce
the environmental impact of eileen and
congestion
so that ends kind of a tech portion of
our talk here and i wanted to jump into
a q a with uh ryan so he's kind of
scripted some questions that he didn't
really share with me beforehand we
wanted to do a sort of live q a to give
you the feel of actually being with us
here as a as an audience
hey thanks daniel and thanks so much for
sharing everything there the stuff that
you and geotab are doing is really
impressive
and i think as you mentioned it was a
little bit more on the technical side
you know by design the conversation that
you just had there with the listeners
can you talk a little bit more about
what the benefits are on the business
side for your customers and how that
works
yeah absolutely um so i mean there's
this uh
impacts of this particular project that
we worked on we do a lot of other things
as well but
i'd also just say that a lot of our
customers actually are cities and have
like their municipal vehicles hooked up
with our
iot device so that being said though
there's a lot of impacts for our fleet
customers as well from something like
this
so if you're you know heavy duty vehicle
driving around the city every time you
have to stop
um that idling uses up fuel it also
takes a lot longer for a heavy duty
vehicle to accelerate again
that uses up fuel and driver time and
things like that um and then from the
city's perspective you know when
that big truck has to stop and then
accelerate again that causes congestion
so for it's a win for the city by
reducing congestion
reducing emissions idle and things like
that but it's also just a win for our
customers
and having to spend less gas and waiting
less time and when you think about one
individual truck it maybe doesn't seem
that big of a deal
but you think back to the san francisco
example with 450 000 cars so most of our
customers don't have that many but some
of them definitely do have
5 10 20 000 vehicles if you're imagining
these little stops constantly across all
of these cities
when you've got 10 20 000 trucks driving
every single day these little
these little improvements they really
add up if you can make those small
changes
and then speaking of certain cities so
you saw on the map before with las vegas
there are some corridors that trucks
like to travel down
and a city once they have this kind of
information can start to think about
things like freight signal
prioritization
so because these trucks take a lot
longer to accelerate there's a larger
congestion impact from them having to
stop
so if you if you're a city wanting to
prioritize freightl on a certain
corridor and minimize the congestion
impact
you can do things like give it an extra
couple of seconds of green when a truck
is approaching to let it go through
so obviously this is a win for the
customer because they don't have to stop
as much and that's a went for the city
not having to reduce congestion
i don't think there's any of us who
wouldn't rather have less congestion on
the streets and so i think that's a win
for just about everyone out there
um you mentioned that you're you're
staying within google cloud as you do
this and it's bigquery there's some data
flow in there can you
can you help describe to our listeners
out there what it would take if you
didn't have bigquery
and the the surrounding tools yeah
absolutely so i think a lot of it would
be what you mentioned at the beginning
if we didn't have all of this
amazing infrastructure on the back end
to do the scaling and manage all that
for us we'd have to spend a lot more
time in that
gray area and actually managing and
building out the infrastructure and
that's not really where
data scientists skills or expertise lies
at least not for me
my expertise and my you know value add
is in solving these business problems
for people and if i had to spend
you know 80 90 of my time building up
the infrastructure the end solution
probably wouldn't be as good because i
can't devote as much time to it so what
we probably would have done then
is using the tools that we had if we
didn't have all this amazing ability to
scale
just really reduce the scope down we
maybe would have had to do it
neighborhood by neighborhood or
maybe city by city and come up with
other kind of limitations to restrict
the amount of data that's going on just
because we wouldn't be able to handle it
but because we're able to we're able to
do this
you know globally which helps us to be a
much more powerful product
makes sense daniel um so hey as we wrap
up do you have any parting words for the
listeners out there advice on how to try
to try out new features
i saw how fast you put scripting into
production i thought that was really
great any tips for the listeners out
there
yeah absolutely so i know i poked fun a
bit at the documentation in the in the
talk there and
some of it has some things i like to
make fun of but overall google's
documentation is actually really really
good so when the new features come out
i dive into the documentation right away
i pull out the examples i try to
implement them
i try to implement them against my own
data so you know everybody watching
you're experts in your own data
you know where your bottlenecks and your
problems are think about ways that you
can leverage these new tools that are
coming out on your own data sets
and if you're not quite there yet
bigquery's got a lot of sample data sets
in there and you can play around with
those
but really need to start digging in and
applying it to actual problems
to understand the the new techniques new
tools and their capabilities and once
you do
it's almost always the case that you can
really quickly implement it in
production and get some really big wins
like
we did with bqgas and like we did with
sql scripting as well
and google's also got some lots of great
champions like uh felipe and lakshman
that are constantly pushing out
content about how to use these new tools
um with examples given and if you can
just go and
replicate their work start making tweaks
thinking about how to apply it to your
own data
you can actually get ramped up pretty
quickly with all of this stuff
that would be my advice daniel great
advice to go along with a great
presentation i can't thank you
enough for coming and sharing your
thoughts today and
what you're doing at geotab and just
wish both you and geotab the best of
luck going forward
thanks friend